the movie Logan has very tightly
constructed and and surprisingly
complete symbolic pattern it's written
as the basic ascent of a mountain the
kind of ascent you find in religious
stories all the time the movie is so
densely structured that up I won't even
try to unpack all the implications of
how it's set up
but hopefully I can give you all a basic
line to follow and trying to interpret
the details
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world the opening of the movie
shows a kind of fallen world the world
of the limit we could call it in a very
real way the movie begins at the bottom
of the world it end that's represented
as the southern border so in my video on
guardians of the galaxy I discussed the
notion of the hero as the one who stands
on the border and in many ways acts as a
kind of guard to defend it but in an
almost paradoxical way at the same time
the hero is a hybrid and straddles the
border himself I mean if you haven't
seen it yet watching that video of
guardians of the galaxy will help you
see the extent of what I'm discussing so
Logan himself is a border crosser he
moves from one side of the border to the
next every every morning and then every
evening because he he works in the
United States and then he returns to
Mexico
where he's hiding and so all the images
line up the desert the fence on the
border the the poor but also we also see
these decadent rich people and mostly
there is this image of death Logan is
dying
his body is falling apart he's not
healing anymore as it as he usually does
because of his mutant powers and his
incapacity to pull his body together is
shown as a form of dissipation of
impotence it's a it also a giving in to
his passions as well as a kind of
selfish self absorption this is all
brought together at the very beginning
of the movie we're waking up from this
drunken stupor he tries to defend his
rented limo from a band of thugs now the
car is a proxy for the body or
how sits the container I mean it doesn't
really matter at which level you see it
what's important is in the fact that he
can't stop it from being damaged
you know his claws come out slowly to
show his impotence but then he also
completely goes berserk and then
slaughters all the thugs and in gruesome
ways all of this is a very powerful
image of this loss of cohesion it is
that loss of control which happens at
the edge another image of this attempt
to bring together to protect or to
that's a to hold on to the vehicle of
life is in the fact that Logan's sole
remaining purpose seems to be to get
enough money to get an ark like Noah get
a boat by which he can escape the chaos
and these different aspects of the edge
they lead us to a funeral in the rain so
death as I said is the frame of this
loss of cohesion and standing on the
brink of death knowing because we've
been told that he's in Phoenix I heard
she was in Phoenix and like the bird
that rises from its ashes standing in
the face of death is where he hears the
first call for transformation burying
the call to ascend I knew it was you
know he doesn't know it yet you know he
doesn't know what's happening because
he's too self-absorbed to attend to a
call for help and so here is this angel
calling him Gabriela is her name get
Gabriel feminine of Gabriel she wants it
she wants him to help her her save what
turns out to be his own clone a feminine
child version of himself which is in
danger of being killed and so by helping
Gabriela and this child by helping
another he is and will be helping
himself so symbolically we have now
these two Logan's the old dying Logan
and the young future Logan and her name
is Laura which is very close to Logan in
terms of of sonority now to understand
the transformation that occurs the
character of a Wolverine itself play
an important part because he's
constantly related through his name
through his appearance and through his
character to a kind of animal passion a
kind of berserker rage
so the basic ascension of the mountain
motif and the whole movie can be seen as
as the difficulties and the
possibilities of taming something of
taking something out of control
something self-absorbed something dead
wild foreign drunk all these images of
chaos which line up this idea of naming
something then taming it bringing chaos
to participate to become the body or the
vehicle of logos of the world so in a
way it's a story of redemption of
creation recreation and redemption
now with the two logan's we have a
beautiful pattern because we can both
see the raw chaotic young Logan in the
little girl you know wild without
manners without self-control but also
silent at the beginning without logos
herself an image of chaos if we've ever
seen one and at the same time we have
the final result of that state the old
dying Logan she's a you know drunk
cynical selfish angry sick and falling
into death even contemplating suicide
now all these images are quite
traditional and for more about this you
can check out the talk I gave called
Pentecost for the zombie apocalypse
where I explained the relationship
between animality and death in biblical
symbolism so Logan has to bring this
child which is at the same time his
future self out of the bottom of the
world out of a prison slavery because
you know just like the Hebrews in Egypt
remember that little girl was a slave to
those that made her he has to escape
this cyborg half-man half-machine
you know this dry technical medicated
etc etc world and bring her
we're bring her to Eden now Eden is of
course an image of the center an image
of the height the the Ascension from the
edge from the bottom of the world
the edge or the bottom of his person and
up towards a place of refuge so that's
why they insist that Eden is north in
North Dakota opposing it to the southern
border but at least what Wolverine has
been going going for him or at least he
he is somewhat following let's say
Jordan Peterson's advice he's trying to
save his father from the underworld and
Professor X lives in an empty falling
water cistern this is of course a very
potent image of the grave a kind of cave
shell but dried up a return to dust the
Bible we see this image when Joseph is
lowered in a cistern in an in an empty
cistern to die on his way to Egypt and
the movies pretty amazing because
Professor X is really the past very
cohesively he he's four things at the
same time he's a kind of scattered
rambling vestige of the past he also
carries a great past sin you know being
responsible for killing all the mutants
he's also this powerful force of
immobilization capable of freezing
people into statues so they can no
longer move forward but but at the same
time he's also this wise father
encouraging Logan and recognizing in
Laura that she is a better version of
Wolverine that needs to be encouraged
and saved so encouraging Logan to say it
to help Laura to help that family in
trouble all of this is pretty amazing
but at the beginning Logan wants to save
Ziggy
but but only he only sees the negative
parts of his father he wants to save him
but he's think he's incapable of hearing
the wisdom and that will come gradually
as the movie progresses so all right so
the
going to eat it but then Logan finds out
that Eden comes from a comic book
Eden exists at the story level of
reality and so obviously Logan doesn't
believe in Eden
you know he's something maybe of a new
atheist with all the drunken cynicism of
a Hitchens though he still moves he
still moves coax by external events and
and slowly attending to the wisdom of
his father but in the act of moving
towards the heart moving towards the
center there will always be resistance
and the biggest resistance comes from
within ourselves and from our own
passions and so enter third Logan shadow
Logan the doppelganger and this Logan is
pure rage pure animal without logos he
only grunts and kills and so there's
this fight between the two Logan's to
decide about future Logan which way will
it go and so we basically got set up
something like this what is the future
will you go up towards Eden or back down
towards chaos now there's a very
powerful scene in the movie where Xavier
confesses his great sin to Logan he
realizes it he knows that he's been the
cause of a horrible thing that's been
keep that's been that's kept underground
kept secret and and then it's in fact
shadow Logan who then goes on to kill
him so Logan is both trying to kill the
tyrannical father and save the wise
father at the same time it's a pretty
amazing setup but is also amazing is
that the death of Xavier is the
beginning of the real movement up the
mountain Logan buries his father and he
can't speak at the funeral he his logos
is is not there he can only utter the
chaos that you know all he can say is
it's got water water water which sounds
like it doesn't make sense but you'll
see why it does make sense and at that
moment
Logan take
Sahn what he needs from xavier but he is
at his lowest point and then like in the
limo scene at the beginning we see him
losing control of his car again and then
he passes out
so here the passing out is a kind of
dying the other baptism one could say
and he awakens symbolically underwater
you see him looking up at these floating
fish and from then on there is this
beginning of an ascent the ascent begins
as literal let's say ascent of logos
because the silent child begins to talk
[Music]
that means the race first in a foreign
language then in English which is a
powerful image of this taming of what is
foreign we're shown the ascent you know
as we see the once again passed out
Logan being lifted up towards the
sunlight in a stretcher and there he
confesses to his futility to his future
he confesses the desire to die the
difficulty of redemption but he's moving
up he's tonsured right his beard is cut
to make him look more like himself more
like the Wolverine that we know and he
starts to heal but he still hesitates he
still stumbles he hesitates one more
time and then finally he commits himself
completely he rushes up the mountain but
to go up the mountain as many things at
once and the movie shows it quite
powerfully in a way that going up the
mountain is a fight but it's also a
dying not the kind of sickness and lock
loss of cohesion which it which is the
death at the bottom of the mountain but
it is the death of self-sacrifice it is
the cross on Golgotha Hill and that's
what happens Logan accepts to die to
himself to be hung on a tree in order to
save others but all but ultimately to
save himself you know there have been
many superhero movies recently which so
show the hero you know with his hands
out in the shape of a cross but but here
the symbolism is
more profound than just a simple visual
reference to the crucifixion so hung on
a tree and in sacrificing himself logan
attains the highest point of logos and
there his shadow also dies and we find
that Laura as she is bring him you know
where Logan could not speak to the death
of his father
Laura speaks clearly she speaks of
identity of the opportunity and the
consequence of identity she says a man
has to be what he is doing what he is
Joey can't break tomorrow it's pretty
good it's pretty effective and now we
know that Laura will cross the border
North finishing the whole set up of a
southern border of death and in northern
heavenly gate of freedom through Eden
and then above through Eden and the
cross at the same time so it's pretty
amazing of course more laterally the
image of going north is playing up with
the references to the Underground
Railroad which which brought slaves to
Canada in order to free them but what's
also amazing is that by going north to
Canada we conclude this basic symbolism
of procession and return this pattern
and so in the end it's a return to the
origin for flora was born in Mexico
logan was born in canada so all in all
it ends up being a very effective movie
now I have to admit there are some
strange aspects to the movie and one is
of course that it seems to participate
in this new tendency of replacing the
masculine with the feminine in a way in
this case we could see we could see that
the girl you know is the potential of
the future and he's moving into this
potential but there's something else
going on you know if we look at it as a
larger social pattern we see this
happening in many media right now the
new Ghostbuster the new Doctor Who a lot
of the Marvel heroes in Marvel
makes were changed into women and and we
see it very clearly in this story of
Moana the movie the Disney movie who
replaces the line of male Chiefs and
adds her pink and rather suggestive
shell on the top of the masculine column
and I think we need to stay away to the
consequences of this rising pattern but
apart from that I would say that in
terms of symbolism Logan Logan shows us
how deep the imagery and symbolism of
Christianity goes in our culture and
despite its gruesome violence this movie
it's it's in many ways the pattern of
the struggle that we all have you know
in us and as for the symbolism of the
mountain for those who might want to
learn about the direct parallel with
with the structures that are in the
Bible especially the the story of Moses
I would suggest to watch my video on
divine patterns in st. Gregory of
nYSSA's life of Moses so that's it I
hope it was helpful so I hope you
enjoyed my interpretation of the movie
Logan this is the third time that we
upload this video we've been having
problems with copyright we think because
the clips are too long and so this is I
think we added it three times to make
sure that it's okay hopefully this time
it'll work out so it's actually a good
opportunity for me to give a shout out
to the person I'm working with who's
editing my videos especially the movie
videos his name is James covenant and
I'm gonna put a link to his channel in
the description and you'll see he's
doing some amazing stuff we're putting
up a Facebook page for the videos and so
put a link to that as well it's a good
way to follow what we're doing to engage
with what we're doing so make sure you
go in like that and finally I just want
to tell you that I finally got the audio
and hopefully some video for the event
that I did with Jordan Peterson in
November in Seattle and so look forward
to seeing that I'm gonna put up the two
talks that I gave and the question and
answers in which Jordan and I and other
people answer questions from the
audience and so there's a still a lot of
stuff going on and we'll see you soon